whenever it's omar i feel really
betrayed because i trust
oma so much uh mute again you want to
talk it out or mute
i i'm good with either one uh i say
let's not me at this time because we did
last time
okay not muting this time i'm near two
people which
harley's theory
how does it always happen that fast i
thought i died i was like
but i did not die not like a juicy
johnny or accusing each other yeah
they're yelling at each other so it's
one of them
[Laughter]
oh god nice all right
yeah all right all right i'm gonna try
and get
what happens if the oxygen goes down we
will fail
at this if there's three of us in here
we're all good i'm with the londoner
oh you have a dog i have a dog oh
man still following we're all good here
we go
uh no i trust you based on the fact that
you just admitted that you were
following me
i feel like
definitely trust bruce we were alone in
a room he could have killed me i also
fully trust omar because instead of me
being like i'm with oma oma was like i'm
with alana so
i trust both i was in the room with
bruce and andy so who was a woman
it could be joe it could be joe or not
weck i can't remember my electrical job
man i'm just trying to get home to my
wife and kids
[ __ ] i don't know who to vote for dude
because he seems
that's all i'm saying unless oh
it's definitely not me [ __ ] i'm going to
electrical i'm announcing it okay
i'm also going to electrical oh there's
a bunch of us going to be an electrical
it should be safe
i was with not wick wait did we are we
breaking this because we're both doing
it
hey jacob come back over here i have to
go do the second half of my wiring thing
somewhere else though
get the hell out of there
are you are you and me buddies are we
buds yes what's going on
omar come over here
it was one of you guys where'd you go
jacob where'd you go i'm with not work
right now omar
well why are they all in here
what do we do here what is this [ __ ]
has anybody accused andy yet
no it wasn't andy i left the room that
alana
jacob and andy were in and jacob was
with me
i pray to your ghost solana
[Laughter]
please forgive this is outrageous they
really did abandon me i was in there
doing talks
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love that there were three people in
electrical with me who are like we'll
stick together and then you all left and
i was [ __ ] dead
i was like what i don't know they're
there
um okay what am i doing let's go
to the reactor shall we and try not to
okay i feel good about donny he looked
like he was on his way to a task he
could have killed me but he didn't
you don't kill me right now folly i need
to go let's go admin let's go admin
oh oh bruce was totally running out of
this room not reporting the body
wait where was it was it in the top
it was in comms is that the top one is
that top right top left top left he ran
straight out what's your defense bruce
what's my defense
well again i didn't see the body
initially and i've actually had that
problem before
i've had that problem before i've walked
by i don't even see jacob jumping to a
vent apparently on my screen
so folly did you see did you only see
bruce
bruce was coming right out of the room
as i went in and outside
and i only saw farley so i was running
up with these guys i couldn't have
killed him
i mean oh i didn't see the dead body oh
i'm sorry bruce it's just
you know it seems like you guys kill me
[ __ ] dummy all right a reactor
meltdown you said
jacob going back and forward there was
uh was a bit odd it was a bit odd
ah [ __ ] we're gonna it's gonna
we're gonna lose what the [ __ ]
no somebody did it okay oh
uh has it been reported uh okay okay
where was this one because i was with
farley and kizzy
so a bunch of us were running around
furiously trying to fix the reactor and
couldn't find where it was
um alma was still trying to do that i
couldn't
i saw you guys go down the hallway that
was the wrong direction i definitely
trust omar i think i'm going to go with
donnie because i think he's in the room
with me but i'm not [ __ ] i think it's
done
and i think donnie is the only one who
is in there but i don't [ __ ] know i'm
pretty sure it's done
please somebody vote for donny just
please sorry no
i [ __ ] it i skipped okay okay we gotta
watch everybody [ __ ]
i think kizzy and omar are definitely
safe
i'm gonna say that much where do i need
to go
let's go to the cafeteria shall we what
are you doing folly [ __ ] you don't
uh what do i have to do what do you want
me to do cafeteria oh buy beverage okay
cool neat i thought you'd never ask
let's get some [ __ ] mountain dew
i guess i was trying to keep up with so
i would know if one of them died but i
know
okay so omar and kizzy and i were all
occupied in the reactor room
i don't know that they stated this death
but i'm quite confident that the
imposter is tony
responded with he wouldn't do that he is
a father yeah that's
no dad's a murderer is all the time okay
that's garbage
i still think it's kizzy we only have
one imposter right now
i really don't think he's kidding omar
did bring up the kids you think it might
have been
oh good girl you guys said kissy but no
one else but me voted for kizzy
yeah daddy eight
i would have been so [ __ ] up and i
would have voted for alana dude
what the hell andy
[Applause]
anybody want to go to the specimen room
okay
all right jacob is that a euphemism
where is this arrow pointing me to what
is going on
hi emma hi hello what the heck
hey hi bruce hi hello no i'm i'm still
alive
hi hi hi everyone uh okay i'm alone i'm
alone in uh
i'm in medical oh there's a there's a
body oh [ __ ]
hmm was it andy did andy die again it
wasn't
okay poopy butt that poopy butt is the
only one who came from the body
that's suspicious jacob's screaming
about poopy butt and it's not poopy butt
then it's jacob
all right so we know the second round
yeah that's true so
voting poopy butt but i gasped it was so
genuine i did hear your gospel to the
extent that i actually thought that you
were dead it was a very
genuine fact to tell everyone else how
genuine your asking was
okay i'm i'm gonna go poopy butt against
my bed of judgment
go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
okay
okay we're on our way to top right right
here i'm at the top
left one now okay almost there wait
wait wait someone already
who was i found the body i found omar's
body i was
i was then i heard omar scream jacob why
are
you
stealing the truth jacob it is very
suspicious that the second that you and
i separated i
just because he's typing so much uh
so much [ __ ] in the chat that just seems
super suspicious
[Laughter]
i'm voting for pedro because you vote
for pedro
one first of us gonna do i think we know
who to watch i don't think alana's an
imposter
unless she's really good at this no i
don't think you are either jacob
oh pedro over there
okay downloading weapons
oh geez oh [ __ ]
oh that's great no idea all i know is i
can trust jacob
killed bruce where was it okay pedro
pedro where was it
suspicious about bruce look i think we
vote pedro
in bruce's honor okay
pedro right oh is he saying folly pedro
is typing like a serial killer
we have 18 seconds before we start
voting it's going to be folly or pedro
and if joe was on the cameras that's
really far away i'm going for the self
okay well i'm sorry
hopefully this works you know also
nice
[Laughter]
more than a minute like yeah i've heard
that about you andy bad reviews from all
your ex
i won't kill you
okay i need to go too that happened
quick didn't it
that's real [ __ ] quick let's do this
first
it's fine we got time
[Music]
i never go immediately because i feel
like these are always drawers to get me
started you know
so nine eight eight
check done
i do trust might be whack i continue to
trust them i continue to trust them
you could have killed me so many times
there you're good
emergency meeting okay i thought it was
it might be one
time it definitely wasn't omar i was
with him the whole time the whole time
too
okay
no the oxygen got sabotaged and i
actually immediately fixed it
so that actually but bruce i'm going to
ask you the question again if you said
you were with omar the whole time then
how did omar die
i wasn't with omar the whole time i
think i said harley fixing that though
no no
yeah no i didn't say that at all ever
a few moments earlier it definitely
wasn't omar i was with him the whole
time the whole time too
i thought it was like i thought it was
the first round because might be weck
and paren were together for a lot of the
time and then parent died
i'm going to vote for bruce based on
might be work suggestion here i'm doing
it
[Music]
[Laughter]
um okay i mean i'm gonna just i could
just follow these dudes
i feel like i'm safe if i just [ __ ]
hang out with jacob
and nitro stays with us right i'm just
wait here for you to do your [ __ ]
we're gonna watch out for [ __ ] watch
out for folly for sure
everyone's together so it's like nobody
can die
this is so funny we're literally all in
a group
oh you poor murderers okay who are we
following
[ __ ] man all right
it's totally flash he's the only one
that's sticking with us has a toss
he says why does it say it's wick
no it's flash nobody was being
suspicious this whole round
so
[Music]
oh my god are we talking i used
in the lab i'm doing some lab stuff also
who else is here oh [ __ ]
already wow wow oh my god
was near you because i just got into the
airlock thing
okay i was trying to find my way to the
[ __ ] reactor how do you get there
you have to go through that little crazy
nickelback says omar was right next to
the body
i was i was up and did not see a thing
because i saw finally run the other way
so that makes nickelback in the lab with
me
as well nickelback is always suspicious
agreed
never trust nickelback
[Music]
i'm sorry guys that's fine okay down
there that's okay you know
but by us saying that we're with you
where we'd be implicated
i have a task up here nobody kill me
please do some wires real quick
i ain't gonna kill you i don't have it
in me that is not true
what happened to jacob wait what
happened to jacob what happened to jacob
jacob's totally dead
jacob yeah jacob's for sure [ __ ] dead
right now huh
did it work what happened oh [ __ ] that's
here jacob we knew he was just jacob
i definitely think andy is innocent um
i'm suspicious of chemicals right now
well because i've been around andy that
i don't think there's any way that andy
could [ __ ] kill someone with them
andy and i were running next to each
other for a little while too and nothing
happened
i'm also very weak we haven't found
anybody yet right there's still three on
the loose i'm still no
but again i feel like there's so few of
us still voting for who
nickelback i voted for nickelback last
round i thought
i think bruce and alana are one of them
they're playing the long game
andy i've been with you so much why are
you so suspicious of me
is it because i'm a woman even if it's
nickelback it's okay
we don't want to go back here anyway
guys
if i'm dead the next round
guys it's alana and it's bruce and it's
joe you have no
logic to say that andy you've been with
me every step of the [ __ ] way
if we can get that back i'll be the door
control person i'll watch over that
okay everybody's [ __ ] right here [ __ ]
three seven nine where is everybody
[Laughter]
yeah you said everyone in the game [ __ ]